Narrator:
These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings,
and are all self‐made.
The sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now, they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
I don't like
to sit behind a desk,
and I love money.
Who wants to help grow
the future of food?
I was sitting here in awe.
It looks ridiculous,
but it works!
It still feels a little bit
like a class project.
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
I'll go 20%.
I'm gonna make
the exact same offer.
This is "Shark Tank."
I could outsell Lori any day
on QVC.
Greiner:
I have a ‐‐ I have a...
He just wants to win.
Yes, I do!
I believe
in your product.
I'll do it for 12.5%.
Oh, my God.
♪♪
First into the tank
is a unique addition
to the beverage industry.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Brandon Zavala,
and I'm the founder
of Apollo Peak,
and I am seeking $100,000
for 10% equity in my company.
Sharks,
you know how it is.
It's been a long day at work.
You're super stressed out,
and all you
really want to do
is unwind
with a bottle of wine.
But you've got
nobody to drink with,
except for maybe your cat.
But cats don't drink wine,
right?
Well, wrong.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Pinot Me‐‐ Meow?
Greiner: That's so cute.
Introducing ‐‐ Pinot Meow ‐‐
Apollo Peak...
Pinot Meow!
... the first‐ever
all‐natural wine
for pets.
So, Apollo Peak pet wines
do not contain alcohol...
[ Laughing ]
... nor grapes.
Instead, they're made
with all‐natural beets
and brewed with herbs,
including catnip, peppermint,
and chamomile...
Oh, my God.
...all with their own
distinctive benefit...
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
... for increased
social interaction.
You're gonna
get it drunk?
Increased
social interaction?
[ Laughter ]
Zavala: So, Sharks,
who would like to partner up
to ensure that every cat and dog
has the opportunity
to enjoy a fine glass of wine
with their human companion?
Wow!
O'Leary: Brandon, is there
actually alcohol in it?
Zavala: No alcohol.
So, the cat wine, uh,
contains catnip, essentially,
which makes cats act like
they're a little drunk, um,
and they're made with
organic beets, too,
for the color.
Herjavec: Do you have wine
for us to taste?
I do, and let me bring
that out for you right now.
Now, Brandon,
are we trying the cat wine?
No.
If we drink catnip,
what happens?
You'll go to sleep,
probably.
It puts you to sleep?
It's actually used in,
like, sleepy ‐‐
sleepy teas
or herbal teas.
Can you put some
in Lori's?
But it makes cats
really frisky, right?
It does, yeah,
and it's essentially the smell
that makes them frisky.
[ Laughing ]
Kevin, you could be the king
of QVC cat wines!
Zavala: [ Laughs ]
[ Laughs ]
Here's one for you.
to try.
Greiner: Thank you.
Moscat ‐‐ Mos‐cat‐o.
You definitely have cute names
for these things.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Here you go, Kevin,
Daymond.
Mark, here you go.
Well, cheers,
fellow Sharks!
Cheers!
Salud!
John: Cheers!
Herjavec: Cheers.
Salud!
And I'll cheers to you
as well.
Kevin, what kind of a wine
is this?
Industrial.
[ Laughter ]
So, Brandon, let's talk about
this business, okay?
Yeah.
Um...
Did you even drink any,
Kevin?
Absolutely not.
[ Laughs ]
That cat is not
drinking this right now.
What's going on?
It's got a hangover.
[ Laughing ]
He drank too much
last night.
No, essentially, what we
want with cats in general
is a comfortable situation.
So usually, when you're at home,
they'll come up,
and they'll actually start
sniffing the drink itself, too.
Um, and when they sniff it,
they'll start potentially
playing with it.
Some of them
will drink all of it,
some of them
will drink a little bit.
It's a gimmick, right?
You're doing this as a gimmick.
Zavala:
The initial Pinot Meow,
yes, it was gimmick.
But we've moved from that.
So, we've learned ‐‐
got out and started making
our dog wines.
You have dog wines
as well?
Yes,
we do have dog wines.
John: [ Laughs ]
It's the ‐‐ the wine you have
in front of you, actually.
Greiner:
What was that one called?
That's the Char‐dog‐nay.
[ Laughing ]
See, here's the thing.
Char‐dog‐nay...
Your names
are really funny.
Herjavec: It's cute!
Zavala: Ridiculous, right?
I mean, they're really funny,
they're really cute,
but I don't see this
as anything anybody would buy.
Cuban:
Well, let's find out.
How many sales?
So, we've sold
just over $192,000.
Over what period?
I ‐‐
Zavala:
The past three months.
Three months?
John: Whoa.
Zavala: Yes.
Greiner: Really?
Yes. That is correct.
Really?
I ‐‐ in a million years,
I never would've thought.
Never would've thought that,
yeah.
I would not have thought that,
either.
So, how did you come up
with the idea?
I was working
in the pet industry, um,
working with
a pet food company.
I was a sales rep
for them.
Okay.
And so, I saw a niche, uh,
for beverage, essentially,
for animals.
What does
one single bottle cost?
This bottle ‐‐
the eight‐ounce bottle
that you see here
is $11.95.
Whoa!
Wow!
What does
it cost you to make?
The cost for
this bottle here ‐‐ $1.25.
O'Leary: I'm a wine guy.
In America,
97% is sold for under $12.99.
So,
we're asking cat owners
to pay the same price
as humans
for a bottle of wine...
Greiner: More.
...except, it's only 40%
of what they pay
$12.99 for, right?
Mm‐hmm.
I mean, are you worried
about that price?
Zavala: Um...
Cuban: Yeah, because,
you know what?
I've heard
a lot of people talk
that when they're looking
to buy wine for their cat,
they ‐‐
they price‐shop first.
[ Laughter ]
So, $100,000 for 10% ‐‐
you're saying the company's
worth a million dollars.
So, you believe you're on scale
to do what?
I believe 2017 will be
between $1.2 to $1.5 million
in sales.
Wow.
Cuban: I believe
every word you've said,
but there's just no way
on God's green earth
I'm gonna be in
the cat wine business, right?
[ Both laugh ]
Of all the things
I could spend my time on,
no disrespect,
but I'm just not
built for this business.
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Mark, you don't appreciate
the finer things in life
for yourself
or for a cat.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Listen,
I think it's really cute.
It's something memorable.
The names are great.
It's not a business for me,
so I'm out.
But, you know, cheers.
You are the pet rock
of the pet food business,
my friend.
Power to you,
but I don't see it
as a staying business.
I like to build
a long‐term business,
so I'm out.
O'Leary:
You know, many years ago,
I actually was
a marketing manager
for Miss Mew Cat Food,
and I learned something
about the cat business.
Cats are very finicky,
as you know.
They are so difficult
to actually
get into a routine.
They are.
And once they cling on
to a flavor or a brand,
they don't change.
If you ship the product
to five families with cats,
and three of them,
or two of them,
make it
part of the cat's diet,
they'll start
buying cases.
I've been there
in that business.
That's a ‐‐
that is a gold mine.
So, here's my offer.
Cuban: Whoa!
♪♪
O'Leary:
I'll give you the $100,000.
I want to be
a third partner,
so 33.3%.
John: Wait a minute!
I'll offer you the $100,000
for 25%.
Daymond
doesn't even drink wine,
so he wouldn't understand
the nuances
of the Pinot Meow.
I may not understand
the Pinot Meow,
but I do understand
scaling.
You want to grow
like a mountain.
You know what
a pile of kittens are called?
What?
A meow‐tain.
[ Laughter ]
I ship $10 million of wine
direct from the winery
to 40 states in America.
It's a logistics nightmare
that we pull off.
I have a huge wine brand.
I'm, like, 18th largest seller
of wine in America now.
Can we counter
with 15% for $100,000,
Daymond or Kevin?
O'Leary: 15%?
Hmm.
I'll go 20%.
I'll do 20% as well.
♪♪
He has
a different pipeline,
which is unproven
in that area.
No, that's not true.
And I have
a very specific pipeline
in that area.
Your most lucrative
opportunity's
to ship direct to customer
and capture all of it.
I'm selling to Petco...
I'm gonna save ‐‐
I was ‐‐
...to Krogers,
to stores for the pet buyer.
I'm saving ‐‐
I'm saving my secret.
Here's what
I'm thinking.
Ooh.
I'm shipping to hundreds
of thousands of people
that know my wine
right now.
What percentage of them
have cats?
It's a huge advantage.
Cuban: Brandon, two offers.
Two offers.
John:
You have the offer now.
Yeah,
what are you gonna do?
Zavala: I'm thinking.
Hmm.
Well, I'll tell you what.
Daymond,
I love your offer,
but one thing
that I really do enjoy
is the margins that we get
for selling online.
You're toast, Daymond.
I'm signed on HSN.
We sell online.
You ready to go?
Yeah.
Would you be willing to counter
anything better, Daymond?
You have to drop
your equity now.
Drop your equity?
Or ‐‐ or ‐ no.
If that's gonna
be the decision,
because of equity ‐‐
that's ‐‐
so you're gonna make the mistake
over something like that?
No, I can't do it.
So, Mr. Wonderful,
I think we have a deal.
Cat wine.
Bad deal!
[ Both laugh ]
I can't believe it!
I love it. I love it.
Thank you, thank you,
I appreciate it.
That's what I love
about "Shark Tank."
Who could even think this?
Yeah.
I love it!
♪♪
Zavala:
Honestly, I can't believe
that I got multiple offers.
I was not thinking
that any offers
would really
come out of this.
I'm really excited
to get a deal ‐‐
absolutely excited.
I think it's gonna help us grow,
and we're gonna become
nationally and globally
recognized now.
I don't want the cat ‐‐
just the wine, just the wine.
The cat is now yours.
Greiner: See, he won't
even touch the cat.
Why ‐‐ why isn't this guy
actually drinking any wine?
What's the matter
with you?
Greiner:
He didn't like it.
Oh, he's ‐‐
look at the hair on him!
[ Laughter ]
Okay, buddy.
That's why
I gave you the cat.
You [Bleep]
That guy made...
[ Laughing ]
I got a black suit on.
John: We are, like ‐‐
He did a deal with a guy
who hates cats.
Yeah, he's dealing
with a guy ‐‐
O'Leary: I love cats.
I love selling cats.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a way
to make growing your own food
more fun and convenient.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Cam Mackugler,
I'm a Vermontrepreneur
from Middlebury, Vermont,
here seeking $500,000
for 10% equity
in my start‐up, Seedsheet.
Seedsheet can make anyone
into a gardening guru.
People want to eat
delicious food
and feel confident
that they're feeding themselves
and their family
healthy, natural,
and ethically‐sourced
ingredients.
So, my company
hacked horticulture
and combined algorithms
with agriculture
to create a product
that turns anyone
into a successful farmer ‐‐
no overalls required.
[ Laughs ]
The Seedsheet features
a weed‐blocking fabric
that's embedded with
an arrangement
of dissolvable pouches,
each containing
a buffer of soil
and organic,
non‐GMO seeds.
Simply unroll the Seedsheet
on top of prepared soil,
add water...
♪♪
...and watch
as the pouches dissolve,
the seeds sprout,
and you convert
your windowsill
into your own personal
farmer's market.
Customers can either buy
pre‐portioned recipe kits,
like cocktail, hot sauce,
herbs, salad, tacos ‐‐
or, design their own
custom Seedsheets.
We're not meal delivery.
We're farm delivery.
So, Sharks,
who wants to fertilize Seedsheet
and help grow
the future of food?
In fact,
I'm so confident in my product,
that I invited Dan
from RecordSetter here today
so that we can set
a world record.
Mark, could you please
join me up here?
Okay.
What am I doing?
Today, Dan?
Well, Mark,
you're gonna be
attempting
a brand‐new
RecordSetter world record
for the fastest time
to precision‐plant
7,000 seeds.
Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
So, what we're gonna
have you do, Mark,
is to go on that side,
and on Dan's command...
Uh‐huh.
...start to first
put that Seedsheet
on top of the garden bed
and roll it in one smooth,
quick trajectory.
Now, why does it
smell so strong?
I might be
a Vermontrepreneur...
Yeah.
but I'm also
an entre‐manure.
Herjavec: Ah!
Greiner: All right, Mark.
Go. Go. Go.
Encouragement here.
Let's go, Mark.
Dan: And go.
Let's go, Mark! Roll,
roll, roll, roll, roll!
Herjavec:
Go, go, go, go, come on!
O'Leary: Yeah.
Faster!
Dan: Have to keep these on.
Flatten it out.
Put your hands in it,
Mark!
Get it over a little bit.
We have to get them
all on the soil.
‐There you go, Mark.
‐Pull it over a little bit.
‐Get in the middle.
‐And...
Herjavec: There you go.
We're good!
Oh, my gosh!
Come on here.
[ Laughter ]
Did I get it?
I'm thrilled to announce
that we have set a brand‐new
RecordSetter world record
for the fastest time
to precision‐plant
7,000 seeds ‐‐
14.15 seconds.
John: All right.
Well, I ‐‐
[ Confetti popping,
whistling ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
I want to thank
my mom...
[ Laughter ]
Awesome.
Thanks.
John: All right!
Can we all
see the product?
Mackugler: Sure.
♪♪
‐Let see what we can take.
‐This one's for you.
‐Here you go.
‐Lori, you have ‐‐
Thank you.
♪♪
So, this is
what comes in a ‐‐
in a kit?
So that ‐‐
we have different sizes,
and these sizes
are all based on
popular garden sizes
that people already have.
Okay.
So,
your 4‐foot by 8‐foot
is your typical container
for an average‐sized bed.
So, if I had a garden
like that in my backyard,
I'd buy this.
You'd buy that.
Exactly.
So, I ‐‐ I buy it.
I just put it down...
Yeah,
and then you water it.
You secure the corner
with the stakes
that are included
inside of that as well, um,
just to make sure the wind
doesn't blow it away.
And then,
do I put more dirt on it?
You do not need to put
any dirt on top of it.
You don't?
You do not.
So, this is
a weed‐blocking fabric.
It allows air flow
through it.
It allows moisture
to flow through.
Cameron,
what's your background?
My background
was in architecture
and environmental
studies.
Okay.
And so, the origin
for the Seedsheet
actually came one summer
when I was house‐sitting
for a co‐worker.
And because it was Vermont,
this "house" was actually
a fully‐functioning
80‐acre dairy farm...
Wow...
and I was paid with
access to their garden,
looking at this garden
that was magnificent, perfect,
and every plant
was the correct spacing apart.
And so, I wondered,
how can you approach agriculture
from an architect's
perspective?
And, so,
how much does it cost?
So our smallest‐sized
kits ‐‐
these are these
container‐sized kits, right?
so that's retailing
for $14.99,
wholesale for $7.50,
and that's costing us
between $1 to $3 to make.
And how ‐‐
what are your sales?
So, our sales to date
are 156 grand,
and that is...
That's this year,
or just from the beginning?
Total.
So, we are 20 months old.
We've only been in business
for one gardening season.
So, you're really trying
to simplify the process
for somebody.
I can obviously
just buy the packs of seeds,
which I'm gonna guess
are a lot cheaper.
If you were to buy
eight different
varieties of seeds,
that'd be eight seed packets.
Each seed packet
for a high‐quality, organic,
non‐GMO seed like ours
is $3 to $4.
So already,
you're saving money.
We are specifically
targeting new gardeners,
and so that fastest‐growing
gardening demographic
is Millennials.
How do you reach them?
Going through retail
is going to be tough,
don't you think?
Sure.
So we've started ‐‐
um, this past spring
was the first spring
that we've been in business.
And we launched
in 46 Home Depot stores.
Right, but retail ‐‐
you've got to deal
with inventory,
inventory planning,
you know,
and then marketing
and mark‐downs and returns
and all that stuff,
right?
Yeah.
Online,
you could build to order.
Yeah.
John: All right,
so here's what I think.
I was sitting here in awe,
I mean, that this is
a disruption,
this is just incredible,
so...
Disruption?
Yeah.
I think it's a disruption
in the space.
I think that ‐‐
or, it's just creating
a new space of home gardening,
making it easy.
But I think
I have to agree with
what some of the other Sharks
have said.
You're saying that you're
targeting Millennials,
but yet, the first step
is in retail.
And you haven't
figured that part out.
I think you have a lot
of challenges at this moment
that's gonna cost
a lot more money,
so I'm out.
Thank you very much.
You know, I ‐‐
I struggle with the idea.
You know,
I'm looking at my son.
Is he gonna order
a kit like this?
Absolutely, 'cause you know,
Millennials love it ‐‐
back‐to‐the‐farm
kind of thing.
Mm‐hmm.
But is he, then,
gonna go to a garden store
and get some dirt
and actually put it down?
Um, no.
I just ‐‐
I don't know if I see it.
I'm out.
Thank you very much,
Robert.
I freakin' love this.
All right!
I love it
for a lot of reasons.
I'm an urban girl,
so I never
got to grow things ‐‐
didn't grow up
around any of that.
But when I first
found out about all of it,
I wanted to be
a hydroponic farmer one day.
[ Laughter ]
Literally, no joke.
Mackugler: [ Laughs ]
That's awesome.
And QVC is
highly‐demonstrable products.
And they have a huge
gardening time of year,
so I think
that I could help you
to get publicity out there,
get people to know
what it is,
get some good sales fast.
But, you only have
160 some‐odd thousand
in sales, right?
Right.
So, I'm gonna offer you
$500,000 for 22%.
Thank you very much
for that offer.
I'll do it for 15%.
Ugh, you know what?
He always just does that.
I'm just ‐‐
Cuban:
Lori, Lori, Lori,
If I love something,
he comes in ‐‐
To keep him at the 22%,
I'll split it with you.
Well, I see it, Mark...
John: Shark fight.
...as if it were you and I
together...
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
...then, I think we should
get a higher percentage,
because we can blow this up
even bigger.
John: [ Laughing ]
I do. I do.
You got to be ‐‐
No, I get that, I get that,
but it's...
I do, because I know the work
that I'm gonna do,
so for 11% for me...
You need to get ‐‐
...I mean,
I ‐‐ I got to hustle.
I got to really ‐‐
I got to really be selling
a lot of things on TV
for you.
What do you think?
With two of you
coming into that,
I would entertain
a higher valuation,
but when we start comparing it
against Kevin's here,
that does [ Laughing ]...
O'Leary:
I could put you on QVC
or anywhere else
you want to.
... make it a little
more difficult for me.
No, you cannot.
You have the queen of QVC.
You have grand, whole,
high‐exalted ruler of QVC.
He's been selling
a lot of booze.
Cuban: Kevin, I think
we know your offer.
O'Leary: But my offer ‐‐
He can sell wine,
but that's it.
My offer ‐‐
Let's compare the offers.
He never even said,
"Thank you."
I let you in,
I could take you out.
[ Laughing ]
O'Leary:
But the point is...
You never said,
"Thank you."
I'm a really good salesman.
That's the bottom line.
John: Shark fight,
shark fight, shark fight!
"I let you in,
I could take you out."
O'Leary:
So, the bottom line is
you could the deal
with two Sharks for 22%...
Herjavec:
Well, hang on a sec.
But you never said
whether or not
you would come in on that.
At 22%, that'd be
the lowest I could go.
That'd be the lowest
you could go.
Yeah. I like it,
but I think it's not
a slam‐dunk by a long shot.
And, so,
that's why I think with Lori,
we get the sales
quickly with QVC.
I'll get you on QVC.
That's not a problem.
If I can get a firm offer
right now
from Lori and Mark for 20%,
I will be happy with that.
Well, I will give you
a firm offer right now
for 20% from Lori.
That's fine.
Would you be in on that?
I said from me.
I'm gonna make it
more interesting for you.
I'll do it for 12.5%.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Cameron is seeking $500,000
for 10% of his planting
innovation company, Seedsheet.
He has an offer from Lori ‐‐
$500,000 for 20% ‐‐
that was immediately undercut
by Kevin's offer
of $500,000 for 12.5%.
You know what, Cam?
He's just
throwing out these offers
just to, like, beat me.
He doesn't really
want your deal.
O'Leary: No.
It's the "Shark Tank"!
[ Laughs ]
He doesn't!
He just wants to win.
Yes, I do!
I believe
in your product.
Is your offer
$500,000 for 20%
with Mark
or without Mark?
Greiner:
I looked at Cam and I said,
I would do
the $500,000 at 20%.
Herjavec: So, Mark,
are you in on that offer?
At 10%,
it's not enough,
because I know the hustle
I'm gonna have to do for you.
Mark, are you in
on the 20%?
♪♪
I'll simplify things
for you.
I'm out.
You're out at any deal.
Yep.
O'Leary: Do you have
a final offer?
You're gonna have to come down
if you want to close this.
I said $500,000 for 20%.
What do you want to do?
♪♪
I'm worried the lettuce
is gonna grow and die
before this is over.
[ Laughter ]
Um, I would love to take
both of your offers right now.
Obviously,
I can only take one.
Um, Kevin...
♪♪
...I really appreciate
your offer.
Thank you very much.
Lori,
I see the value of yours
with your experience
in the home‐gardening side.
Lori, I would love
to do a deal with you.
Yay!
John: Yeah!
I thought
you were gonna mess that up.
Oh, good!
You did the right thing.
Now I'm excited, good!
Thank you.
Lori ‐‐
Lori can sell.
Cuban: Congrats, Cam.
Thank you all. Appreciate it.
Good job, Cam.
♪♪
Whoo!
I thought I would squeeze
you down a bit there, Lori,
for sure.
You...
John:
Congratulations, Lori.
You...
Mackugler:
I am so very honored
to have multiple offers.
In the end,
Lori has a lot of experience
with home and garden products,
so it was a great fit ‐‐
destined to be
a good partnership.
Narrator: In season seven,
Jeff Klimkowsi, Sean Riley,
and Ryan Meegan
struck a deal with Mark Cuban
for Dude Wipes ‐‐
disposable wipes for men.
300K, 25%.
Yeah!
‐Whoa!
‐Let's go.
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Klimkowski:
For a brand like ours,
pioneering a new category,
it's important
to get the word out.
Man: Pick up a Dude Wipe
and take it...
...To the hole.
We put out a funny video,
and Mark
jumped at the opportunity
to make a cameo.
Now, that's fresh.
Meegan: Our viral video
has received
over a million views,
and that's translated
into a lot of business for us.
Riley:
The year before "Shark Tank,"
our sales were $250,000.
Since "Shark Tank,"
we've grossed
$3.2 million.
Today,
we have meeting with Walgreens.
If all goes well,
this could be our biggest
retail deal to date.
As a health, well‐being,
and beauty retailer,
your product definitely
hits that sweet spot
for our customers.
We've decided
to push your product
and do 4,200 orders.
We had a good feeling
about this meeting,
but it blew
our expectations away.
This deal alone's gonna
double our retail presence.
Now, we're gonna be in
over 7,200 locations
nationwide.
So this is where we test
new merchandising concepts,
and I want to show you
how your product's
gonna come to life.
‐Perfect.
‐Looks good.
Riley: "Shark Tank" experience
has been great for us.
It's allowed us
to build our brand
to dudes
all across the country,
and it really does show
that if you follow your idea,
you can grow it
into a big success.
♪♪
My name is Mylen Yamamoto,
and I'm from Honolulu, Hawaii.
I'm a fourth‐generation
Japanese‐American,
and my grandpa
fought in WWII.
And my dad has worked for
Hawaii's Department of Education
for over 40 years,
and it's because of him
that I became a teacher.
There are a lot of different
entities that you can use
to get your product
to market.
I've been teaching university
entrepreneurship classes
for the past seven years.
I realize it's one thing
to teach entrepreneurship,
and quite another
to be an entrepreneur.
It was on a flight to Asia
where I had a simple problem
I'm sure thousands of people
have also experienced.
That's when
I came up with an idea
to innovate a product
that hasn't changed
in over 4,000 years.
I'm gonna miss you so much.
Let's stay in touch.
[ Applause ]
Yamamoto: It's scary to leave
a steady income,
a place that I've known
for seven years,
and going out
and risking everything.
But, it's important to prove
to myself and my students
that I can make this business
a success.
This is my big moment.
I've been teaching
entrepreneurship for so long,
that now it's time
to walk the walk
and put my lessons
to practice.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, see that handsome
sushi man over there?
We got married two weeks ago,
so excuse me...
Congrats.
Greiner: Aww.
...thank you ‐‐
any chance to be carried.
Plus, these slippers
are really hard to walk in.
No kidding!
[ Laughter ]
Konnichiwa, Sharks!
I am Mylen Yamamoto,
the inventor of CropSticks
from Honolulu, Hawaii,
and today I'm seeking $75,000
in exchange for
12.5% of our company.
CropSticks
is re‐inventing the hashi.
Repeat with me, Sharks ‐‐
hashi!
All: Hashi!
Yamamoto:
That was awesome!
3 Hashi is a Japanese word
for chopsticks.
Oh!
Chopsticks
are traditionally paired
with what we call
a hashi‐oki.
Repeat!
All: Hashi‐oki!
Yamamoto: Very good.
But in modern‐day commerce,
it's very expensive
for restaurants
to maintain this rest,
leaving chopsticks to lay alone
on dirty, germy tables.
Chopsticks have been around
for over 4,000 years,
and that's because
this ancient utensil
is simply amazing.
But they're not
without faults.
For example,
these chopsticks
are circular in shape,
and when placed on the table,
they tend to roll off.
And these chopsticks
are made of wood,
killing millions of trees
every single year
for a product
we simply throw away.
Ha!
[ Laughter ]
When you split them apart,
you can get splinters!
[ Growls ]
But, CropSticks
solves all these problems.
CropSticks is the first‐ever
disposable chopstick
with a built‐in rest.
Simply snap it
apart horizontally.
Greiner: [ Laughing ]
Yamamoto:
The top becomes a rest.
Cuban: Oh.
Try to do that with
traditional chopsticks,
it's impossible.
What a good idea.
[ Growling ]
Ha!
Herjavec:
[ Growling ]
Ha!
Yamamoto:
No more splinters,
and CropSticks is better
for the environment.
It's eco‐friendly
because we make our CropSticks
out of bamboo.
Simply put, CropSticks
are chopsticks re‐invented.
This is my
sushi‐chef husband, Ron.
He's gonna pass out
some sushies for you.
Herjavec: Thank you, Ron.
Ron: Here, Robert.
Yamamoto:
I'll be right back ‐‐
gonna change into
something more modern.
Lori's is
a California roll.
Thank you.
Mr. Wonderful.
O'Leary: Thank you.
Thank you.
Daymond,
we have an eel‐avocado for you.
John: Thank you.
O'Leary:
Mmm. That's good.
Herjavec: Oh, wow.
Ron: And, Mark,
here's spicy tuna for you.
Awesome!
That's what's up!
Hello. [ Laughing ]
Oh, Mylen,
what happened to you?
So, it broke off easily ‐‐
has a little
scoop‐out section here.
Mm‐hmm.
And you can just
lay it down.
It's very clever.
Thank you.
Greiner:
So, what are your sales,
and how long have you
been in business?
No, no,
don't get there yet.
[ Laughing ]
To the sales,
we had a kickstarter in March,
so we sold 21,800
off of that.
Good!
And right now,
we have conditional
purchase orders for 190,000,
and of that in profit
is $125,000.
Yeah!
Wow!
So, our profit margin
is about 65%.
Wow, good for you.
Thank you, Mark.
Who's your
purchase order from?
So, we have one from
a very large hotel chain.
It's a Hyatt.
And we also have one
from a large
Asian distribution company.
And, do you have
a patent on this?
We have
a provisional patent.
Herjavec: Mylen,
what's your background?
I was a teacher.
I got my Masters
in Communication.
My first teaching job
was as an English teacher
in Japan.
And after that,
Loyola Marymount found me
and hired me
into their department
to teach entrepreneurship.
Oh, that's cool.
Teach entrepreneurship?
Oh, you were teaching
entrepreneurship?
Yamamoto: I was.
and I just stepped down
from the position
to do entrepreneurship.
To be an entrepreneur.
Let's get back to
the business for a moment,
because I was actually
involved in a deal
that made bamboo knives
and forks.
What I found out is,
the restaurant will not pay
1/8 of 1 cent more
for a bamboo spoon.
They couldn't couldn't give
a flying "beep"!
So, if you're
a restaurant chain,
generally you buy these
from a distributor.
You care about every cent
in what you pay.
What do yours cost
versus those?
Two ‐‐ um, we sell it
for 10 cents.
We sell it to distributors
for 6 cents.
We make it for 2.2 cents.
Good for you.
Herjavec: And what does
a restaurant today
pay for them?
It depends.
So, middle‐tier,
like your P. F. Chang's,
pays about
3 cents to 8 cents.
Then your high‐tier market,
like your Nobu,
pays anywhere from 8 cents
to as much as 17 cents.
You will not be able to charge
a cent more for this.
Nobody will care.
But if they can buy it
for the same price ‐‐
That's our ‐‐
Okay, so, that's our go‐to
market strategy, Mr. Wonderful.
Middle‐tier,
high‐tier market ‐‐
sell to them first,
scale up,
bring our costs down,
then go to
those Panda Express.
Greiner: Do you have
a distribution company
that is saying,
"I'm gonna take you
all these places"?
Not yet.
Not yet. Why not?
Do you know?
We are still
relationship‐developing,
especially the one
that bought into us already.
We want to make sure we get
the logistics right on that.
Mylen, I don't think
anybody really cares
about branding
in chopsticks.
I don't think anybody says,
"Make sure my chopsticks
are CropSticks."
It's done
at the distributor level.
If you came out here
and said to me,
"Look, we're gonna
price these things
at the lowest point
to get distribution,
and everybody
that buys chopsticks
will have
only one alternative ‐‐
buy the old ones
at 6 cents,
or by my new innovation
at 6 cents.
Mine's better.
It gives you an extra bonus
of having this on the top."
That's a strategy
that makes sense.
You seem to be going
in a different direction,
which I don't think
is gonna work.
I...
I think ‐‐
you remind me of Bambi
in the bamboo jungle...
Greiner: Oh!
...and you're about
to get squashed.
I'm out.
♪♪
Cuban: Mylen, first,
congratulations.
You know, you've actually
gone from academia
to, you know,
implementation.
Thank you.
But it still feels a little bit
like a class project.
I think ‐‐ I think you're
being overly‐optimistic.
I think there's
a little bit of realism
that's not there.
I'm out.
John: I like the product.
Um, I think it really is
a B‐to‐B play ‐‐
as you're doing ‐‐
just selling directly to
the Hyatts and restaurants.
Um, it's a little
too early for me,
so I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
To your points about
being the Bambi
in the bamboo forest...
Greiner: Aw.
John: [ Chuckles ]
...I‐I've had less than $20
in my bank account.
I know what it's like
to be strategic
and make something
out of nothing happen.
All right,
I don't think you're a Bambi.
I can feel that from you.
I admire the fact
that you left
a safe environment in school,
and you actually did it ‐‐
you started a business.
Thank you, Robert.
Um...
the bad news is,
Kevin's right.
If you can't sell it
for the same price,
it's a commodity.
You're gonna have
a very challenging time
adding value
to a commodity.
I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
O'Leary:
Then, there was one.
Lori.
I do not see you
as a Bambi at all.
I see you as
a strong, smart woman.
Um...
I think you did
a better mousetrap.
I mean, it was clever.
Thank you.
But...
I don't see it
as a business for me.
But I hope
that it blows up for you.
I'm out.
John: Good luck.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate your time
and the feedback.
Thank you.
Good luck.
‐Okay, good luck.
‐Sayonara.
Herjavec: Those shoes look
really hard to walk in.
They really are.
I'm gonna take them off.
[ Laughter ]
Excuse me!
Bye, thank you.
Greiner: Bye.
♪♪
Greiner:
How dare you call her
Bambi in the forest.
Like this...
Ugh.
[ Chuckles ]
You have no heart.
O'Leary: That's what's
gonna happen to her.
John: Uh...
Come on,
I mean, you know.
You know
this isn't gonna work.
One of few times
you're right.
It's a commodity.
People aren't
gonna pay a premium.
O'Leary:
It was nice knowing her.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the tank
is a product to ensure
you're covered wherever you go.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Rick Pescovitz
from Cincinnati, Ohio.
I'm the inventor and owner
of Under the Weather,
and I'm seeking $600,000
for a 10% interest
in my business.
Wow.
Under the Weather
has revolutionized
the outdoor spectator
experience.
Have you ever
frozen your butt off,
been poured on in the rain,
or even pelted by hail
while watching an outdoor event?
I have and it sucks,
let me tell you.
[ Laughs ]
Mother Nature
can be a bear.
I'd like you to meet
Jordan and Stacey.
Their kids, like mine,
chose to play outdoor sports.
We had Fall soccer...
[ Thunder rumbles ]
[ Laughter ]
...and ‐‐ and you never know
in the Fall.
You got wind,
you have the wind.
[ Wind whistling ]
Oh! Awful!
Aw!
Pescovitz:
How miserable can it be?
[ Laughter ]
Cuban:
Out with the wind!
Then we're not done,
'cause then we have
winter football.
Oh, my.
Oh, it's starting to snow!
[ Laughter ]
Oh my gosh,
it's snowing!
It's Arctic, it's cold.
[ Laughter ]
You think you're safe
in the summertime,
but you're not because
we bake in the heat
with those rays of the sun.
It's boiling out.
[ Laughter ]
It's frustrating, okay?
After 15 years of this stuff,
I had enough.
And that's when I invented
the Under the Weather
Sports Pod.
[ Laughs ]
I will show you
how easy it is to pop open.
Each pod weighs
less than seven pounds ‐‐
completely portable.
Greiner: Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Water ‐‐
Water‐ and wind‐proof.
It's also treated
with a coating
that prevents the harmful rays
of the sun getting you.
It's got transparent sides
on three sides.
[ Laughs ]
You will not miss
your little guy's goal,
if he has one,
no matter where he is
on the field.
And last of all,
we have
the connecting versions
which are the MyPods.
Is there a wall
between it?
There is.
There's windows that go up,
doors that go up and close.
[ Laughter ]
My wife yells a lot
at the games.
Zip 'em out.
I zip it up.
Let's take a look.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban:
That's hysterical.
It looks ridiculous,
but it works!
35 degrees warmer in there
than the outside.
It is ‐‐
'cause of body heat?
Yes, from your own body heat ‐‐
warms it up.
So, Sharks, which of you
would like to get in a bubble
and help our sales double?
I would love to see
if a couple of Sharks
would like to
come give it a try.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Pescovitz:
Wow, we got ‐‐ come on,
we'll all take turns.
We'll take turns.
John: Wow!
Lori, I know you're
from the Windy City.
I know. I know.
I got to see this.
I want to see
if they tip over.
Lori...
Greiner: Okay.
Pescovitz:
They better not tip over.
Let's get you in there.
[ Laughs ]
Lori,
get your shoes in there.
Yeah, you got to put
your shoes in there.
Oh, my God.
I feel like we're Pod People.
Okay there you go.
We got the Fall ‐‐
what's going on?
It's like a confessional!
It's raining!
You better zip that up, man!
[ Laughter ]
[ Rain falling ]
Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
You think that's good,
right?
Somebody tip 'em!
[ Laughs ]
So, your kids are out there
actually playing in this crap,
and you're like...
Yeah!
Yeah, but they're
getting to run around.
They're getting exercise.
They look like
they're in jail!
Was it comfortable,
Daymond?
Yeah, I mean, it was.
It's a little bit hard
to see through the plastic.
Herjavec: Right.
Yeah, no, it's great.
Inside is great, I...
Was there a bathroom
in there?
Greiner: It works.
[ Laughs ]
O'Leary: So, tell us
where you're selling them,
how you're selling them,
and give us your forecast
for how much
you're gonna sell.
85% have been
online sales.
Really?
How much does one cost?
Retail is $99.99 apiece.
Okay.
Okay?
That's reasonable.
Uh, my cost landed,
is about $23.
John: Okay.
About a 75% margin.
Rick, why don't we get down
to the sales.
O'Leary:
What do you got?
Well, we did about
$2 million the last year.
Wow.
Nice!
We netted about
a million dollars.
He made
a million dollars
Made a million dollars.
Congratulations.
Herjavec:
Yeah, congratulations.
Thank you, Mark.
Thank you.
You're a millionaire!
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Millionaire ‐‐ well,
I don't know about all that.
I got to put it back in.
Do you have a patent
on it?
I do.
And we have a
utility patent pending
on the adjoining ones
and this shape.
Then, we have
nine design patents.
What's your background?
Okay, so,
I started a company
that did embroidered apparel
and promotional items.
At the height of
the business,
we were doing
about $8 million.
I hated what I did.
I hated that business,
and I sold it in 2012
for, uh, $3.5 million.
My brother was a partner,
and, uh...
[ Voice breaking ]
And my brother ‐‐
they had three great kids,
great marriage.
And...
[ Cries ]
[ Crying ] The week
before Christmas 2010,
we left Detroit,
and it was snowing.
And he skidded,
and got broadsided by a semi.
Oh, no.
Herjavec: That's awful.
Ugh.
So sorry, Rick.
Oh, we're so sorry.
The day before that ‐‐
[ Sniffles ]
I still have the e‐mail ‐‐
'cause I'm known in my family
to come up
with crazy‐ass ideas.
I believe it.
And I had this e‐mail,
and I said, "Mark," ‐‐
that's my brother's name ‐‐
"What do you think, man?
I got this.
I like this idea."
This idea?
He said, "This time,
you're on to something."
Oh, wow.
He was gone, but...
Greiner: But he's ‐‐
I believe
he knows what you've done.
[ Exhales sharply ]
That's a tough story,
Rick.
Greiner:
Yeah, we're so sorry.
[ Sniffling ]
We're so sorry.
He'd be so proud of you,
though, I think.
So proud.
It's, uh...
Herjavec:
But, you know what?
You proved him right,
right?
Thank you.
Yeah.
What made you want to become
an entrepreneur?
[ Normal voice ] I ‐‐ I like to
wear what I want every day.
I don't like
to sit behind a desk,
and I love money.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
I love money.
John:
Sounds like all of us.
Ta‐da!
What's your
inventory‐management system?
Uh, my head.
Ooh.
Let ‐‐ let me understand
your numbers here, right?
Okay, so, how many units
did you sell last year?
I ‐‐ I think
we sold 22,000.
Okay, so those numbers
add up to...
Wow!
22,000 units?
Yeah.
That's amazing.
That's impressive!
All right, so you're asking
for $600,000 for 10%.
It doesn't look like
you need the money.
What's the purpose
you're here?
I'm a salesman
and a product guy.
I want expertise
on worldwide distribution.
There's 70 million
soccer parents just in the USA.
My wife,
who's been in marketing forever,
thinks we should be in retail.
But here's the thing ‐‐
the knock‐offs are out there.
So, you want a partner
for all those aspects
because you're the only one
making the decision on,
"Yes, should I take up that
real estate
so they don't take
somebody else?"
Absolutely.
"Should I reduce this price?
Should I continue growing
more SKU?"
That's what it is?
Absolutely.
All right, well,
I'll get it started.
I'm, uh...
I‐‐
All right, here we go!
Yeah, I would love to do
the deal,
but I think you keep online
to yourself,
and I think you license retail
to somebody else.
Let them deal
with all the headaches
so, you keep all the margin
and keep cranking those goods.
Let them deal
with all the warehousing,
on‐boarding,
and all that stuff.
So ‐‐
Who would
you license it to?
Uh, it's a person called
None of Your Business.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
Great company,
None of Your Business.
Shut Your Pie Hole.
Um...
‐[ Laughs ]
‐So, I'll give you
$600,000 for 20%.
Appreciate the offer, Daymond.
Good offer!
I'm going to make
the exact same offer ‐‐
600K for 20%.
That was on my mind before
he started all that noise.
I think you need
a little inventory system
and accounting.
Rick,
let me tell you where I'm at.
I actually don't think
you need help.
I think you're killing it.
You have the same problem
I had when I was your size ‐‐
is you want to do everything
'cause you can.
But you got to let some
of this knock‐off stuff go,
and you just got to be
more efficient,
and you're gonna get there.
I don't think you need
the investment.
I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
I appreciate it.
And I appreciate the kind words.
Well Rick,
you've got two offers.
So, you can wait for Lori
and Mark,
or you can take
a bird in the hand.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Rick has two offers on the table
for his portable
outdoor pod business,
Under the Weather.
Well Rick,
you've got two offers.
So, you can wait
for Lori and Mark,
or you can take
a bird in the hand.
Rick:
Well, I tell you, I came here
to make a partnership.
Mark, are you interested?
Yeah,
I'm definitely interested.
Um, are you doing any type
of SEO or advertising at all?
We just started.
We're doing 500 bucks a month
in the last four months.
We'd done nothing before that.
So, everything is completely
word‐of‐mouth.
We've spent 11 grand
on advertising in two years.
Outstanding!
That is incredible.
Wow!
John: Rick, I gave you
an offer in Spring, right?
It's now...
What are you doing, Mark?
...around Fall right now,
all right?
I'm listening.
I'm listening!
So, here's what I'll offer.
I'm gonna offer you $600,000
for 15%, right?
But I also want an option
to buy another $600,000
for another 10%.
It's gonna take a lot of work
and effort on my part that ‐‐
You have time for me?
I always have time for you,
right,
but I also have a big staff
that ‐‐ that will take over
your accounting if need be,
work on your inventory,
work on your software, right,
to do all the blocking
and tackling.
But if I'm growing it, right,
I want to be able to take
advantage of that, as well.
On both of these,
I'll let you put the money
right in your pocket.
Okay, when is the option period?
How long ‐‐
12 months.
♪♪
Deal.
Done.
[ Lori chuckles ]
♪♪
Thanks, Rick.
Appreciate it.
We're gonna make
a lot of money.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mark.
Wow.
That was an experience
right there.
My brother Mark meant
a whole lot to me,
and now I'm partnering
with a guy named Mark,
and maybe that's fate.
I'm happy.
I'm very happy.